yeah brian sashaloft is starting
tonight's team coverage with reaction
from teachers all across the district
denise and brian it's been a long
difficult road through distance
education and the teachers i spoke with
tonight are excited to get back
to in-person learning but this is all
coming together especially quickly
so many educators are asking parents to
be patient
as they navigate through these next few
months as a teacher
i cannot wait to be back in the
classroom with my students
after nearly a year of distance learning
teachers across the valley
are ready to get back to class welcome
back
let's get on with it and get this train
rolling
once again clark county school district
leaders announced
their reopening plan wednesday with a
hybrid transition for all grades
starting march 22nd and an option to
bring pre-k through fifth grade back to
the classroom full time on april 6th
that's the ultimate goal is getting kids
back into school
but it's going from transition to
transition to transition it's just
it's just kind of a whirlwind ccsd
teacher andrea roach
is happy to hear the news but she's
asking the community to consider the
unexpected
enormity of these changes and bear with
educators
as they do their best please be patient
with the system be patient with the
process
please be patient with your teacher so
they can all work toward the ultimate
goal
of learning in person together we've
definitely pushed through and like
pulled through like i think teachers
have
and students have shown like an amazing
resilience this year
now the teachers i spoke with say they
don't really have any details yet as to
what this transition will look like they
learned about it when we did today
they're asking ccsd leaders to
communicate with them as much as
possible so they can be prepared
and keep families in the loop